this is our last day for this uh needle
and we're jumping from where we were
before the introduction to about a
quarter of the way into the book and
then the phenomenology of a spirit is a
big thick you know you can use it to
crack walnuts technical book you know
it's very dense there's a lot going on
in it this is probably the section that
has been paid the most attention to in
the last hundred years and if there's oh
there's one section that people who read
Hegel only pay attention to you know
things they skip everything else it's
this section that they actually pay
attention to and the reason is because
of the master-slave dialectic because
that's seen as kind of a interesting
concept that we can pact a lot of things
into a lot of great philosophers in the
twentieth century
have tried to see human relations in
general as being a reflection of this
dialogue so that's where we're headed I
want to give you a little preview of
that to begin with and then we'll do the
dialectical path and actually get there
so you know sometimes it's translated as
lordship and bondage but the master
slave works just fine and the basic idea
is this that human beings are put into
relations with each other where some are
subordinate and some are superior and
this doesn't actually have to do with
quality of who the people are oftentimes
these are just you know chance
occurrences and now what happens is the
person who's got the superior position
they get to call the shots they get to
decide what goes down they're the ones
who have gained recognition they're the
ones who are treated as if they matter
as if they're real people the under
class and it could be slavery in the
traditional sense Marx thought of this
in terms
the proletariat and as opposed to
everybody else people have looked at
this in terms of gender relations
some people have looked at education as
a process like this I remember my
professor and graduate school saying
this is a perfect depiction of what
happens in graduate school we don't let
you out until you're screwed up er you
know we make you undergo certain things
so it's got a lot of the adaptation
jean-paul sartre
we might read in some other classes
ended up saying goodbye to all human
relations between people he's got a
famously said hell as other people and
if you buy under the master-slave
dialectic as being the key for
understanding things it makes sense that
you would see things this way you can
look at the workplace this way you know
even if you make it up into the the
upper management you've still got some
somebody over you is telling you what to
do and making you jump through hoops so
the way the master-slave dialectic goes
is the master is the one who's in the
privileged position they get to decide
you know what what happens they get to
make the other people do what they want
and the other person as Hegel says
exists for them they're not seen as
having independent existence on their
own they exist as as part of you know
think of team right or think about the
way that I think some professors think
about students you know what's the
actual role of education you guys to
become educated right you're here so
that something will happen within you
and us professors you know if you looked
at us in the right way I think it was
the right way to look at it we're sort
of condiments were there to facilitate
you actually learning with us some
professors look at it as and I had a lot
of
pastors like this well we're the
professor's what we do matters what you
do is just sort of a pale shadow
imitation of what it is that we do we
write articles you write research papers
but your research papers are never going
to be anywhere as good as our articles
so you know we're going to assign them
to you to make you jump through hoops
and then we'll let you out and if you
learn something along the way
that's good but that's not what it's
really about it's really about you know
me being the professor the sage on the
stage and Brody is being my captive
audience that I make you know dance to
my tunes that's the way you know a lot
of people regarded education that would
be very similar to the master-slave
dialectic I have independent existence
you have merely what Hegel call it
dependent existence you exist before me
now I'm going to say that to you you
know as I'm running through that don't
you have any feelings
because any of you have any any
professor student relations or think
back to high school any connections like
that did you experience that would that
feel like irritation what else yeah so
you can feel discouraged you feel you
feel like either you can actually like
internalize that and you actually do
feel less because of that or you you can
tell if they're trying to push that on
to you but you don't you just don't
matter to them right what else what
other kinds of feelings will crop up for
you makes them look kind of
because sometimes those teachers that
have a opinion are also well yes that's
true that's that's the worst
I remember getting detention when I was
in middle school for telling a teacher
and he was wrong when he actually was
drawn and and that's why I had a
detention for it because I was breaking
class discipline and that I was really
surprised that when my mom came to show
up
she took the teachers side I was like
wait a second you're supposed to
actually you know be on the side of
truth justice and cetera et cetera
you know I'm actually on that side for
once for one you know the news the one
time where I actually was right and what
I did why did you back to heaven she
didn't do that you know and I look back
and I look at that guys being kind of a
finger amis myself Hegel would say that
those feelings are reflection of
something that's going on within your
psyche because of the dynamic that
you're placed into when you're stuck in
a workplace right and you have a
velocity of complete jerk and they're
just they're enjoying being a boss and
it's kind of arbitrary and capricious
they're getting paid way more than you
are
your schedule is terrible the working
conditions are good and you know they're
not going to get any better you how many
of you have been in situations like that
I don't work a lot of jobs like that
anybody worked in restaurants is
probably and you know similar
experiences or retail retail is waffle
for that sort of thing to when you feel
that kind of reaction those feelings are
reflection of what a Gogol's alienation
being alienated being made to be less
than what you are being made to absorb
somebody else's take on things including
the their take on you plus your when
you're treated as a human being when
you're treated respectfully you are
given when Hegel calls recognition when
it's the other way around when you're
just there
or somebody else you're being treated as
if you're just there to give them
recognition you might even have some
friendships like that you know you know
the one friend who no matter what story
you tell they always have a better story
than yours and they tell it immediately
after you tell your story and your your
that's there and basically to listen to
that yeah they have any friends like
that they would be placing themselves in
a similar situation and if you're stuck
in that kind of relationship that would
be an experience of what Hegel's calling
alienation as well and the alienation
has to do with not getting the
recognition that you deserve
now ankles gonna place this in terms of
human history so we want to work our way
to that and see how he gets there and
you notice I put a few things on the
board so this is kind of review a little
bit of last class consciousness that's
all of you that's hating to me that's
every human being consciousness is we
use this term subject each one of you is
a son you are able to act you are able
to choose for yourself you are able to
accumulate experience over time you are
sort of a a point in the universe where
things happen there's something solid
about you that continues over time right
now for instance swimming right you
didn't just start screaming yesterday
this is something that characterizes you
right reading these these sci-fi and
fantasy books that's something that
characterizes you those are those are
enduring
traits and these make some kind of you
know not philosophical them kind of
trivial but this is what makes up a
human person right so each one of you is
this consciousness each one of you is a
subject you have relations to all sorts
of objects in the world you perceive
things and that's a back and forth
relation you contribute something to
that the way in which you you view a
situation is not and we talked about
this last time it's not that you know
there's just information coming to you
with null sort of filters that you place
on it it's not as if
you don't extend yourself out into the
world and then interpret things in
certain ways but you do grasp things
that are doing than you if you didn't
you'd be a total negative narcissist
right what is the narcissist a person
who thinks the whole world revolves
around them that the whole world is
merely there for their subjects what
you've experienced part of why you guys
are not insufferable narcissus very few
students have been embarrassed actually
are but you know why you can people can
actually like you is because you are
aware of objects that are different than
you and resist your desires and you have
to adapt yourself to them so at the time
and then you could think of anything you
like as objects it could be you know a
pen and if you want the pen to write you
have to actually use it in a certain way
right you can't just like put it there
today pen I command you right it's not
gonna work until we get a super
electronic tennis or some other science
fictiony kind of thing if you want to
read the stuff that's on the deeper you
know you can't just command a paper read
yourself to me you actually have to read
it which means you have to be able to
read you have to be able to pay
attention you have to adapt yourself you
can think of objects as large as of
course a study right you guys are
involved in college education you know
you've had to adapt yourself to a lot of
things so there's the relationship and
then what makes consciousness a
different kind of object in the world is
the fact that he has a reflexive
relation to itself we've talked about
this before
every one of you is aware not only of
your environment you're aware of
yourself right
so when I said for example you know
something about swimming you immediately
associated that with people that's part
of my identity and you know you've
probably thought back to like earlier in
the semester where it came up good
memories about yourself and interactions
and things like that any one of you
could have a similar types of reflexive
knowledge based thinked memory
imagination cognition all these sorts of
things so you may actually not only know
Hajus you know yourself you acquire
knowledge of yourself
did any of you know yourself inside and
out you know completely fully I sure
don't I'm still finding out things about
myself that surprised me sometimes good
sometimes bad and you're in that process
too
here's where it gets particularly
interesting because we already have this
with Descartes right it's a lot thinking
about itself
how do you actually carry this this
process out this reflexive process you
do it in part through the objects in the
world that you engage with so you're not
a pure thinking being all by yourself in
some god-knows-where spirit land
carrying out this this you know pure
Cartesian and code Ito kind of a kind of
process you are a body you exist here
you exist with the particular
characteristics that you have and the
particular history that you have and we
all share something more you know more
general more broad right but you have to
relate to that through your environment
through objects in the world now here's
where it gets even more interesting so
we talk about the objects as if there's
you know den things like this right the
chalk is merely a tool right is this
truck going to get up and grow legs and
walk around somebody messing around I'm
going to do Disney cartoons probably and
it's conceivable him says well it's
conceivable it's possible but we're not
gonna go down that route what are some
of the objects in the world that
mattered you the most what's up yeah you
jumped right right to the main thing the
objects in the world that value that we
value the most that that make the most
difference to us the death most meaning
tend to be other human beings why well
because every other human being is a as
a subject and we're able to have
relations with them but you just can't
have with other objects can can your
your your paper lovely no hopefully
nobody says yes right she has some weird
the paper fetish kind of thing even if
you have a weird weird fetish about it
that doesn't love you it doesn't feel
affection towards you you just have a
kind of strange affection towards it can
your parents love I'm not asking if they
actually do I hope they actually do but
in theory yes right
sooner or later down the line most of
you will end up being married or in some
sort of long-term relationship some of
you probably are already you want that
person to have certain relations towards
you as a subject not just as an object
if you treat people like objects if you
only treat people like objects you're
missing out on a huge part of life
aren't you
and we can't evaluate people just as as
objects think about when we're doing say
medical stuff right is it is it possible
to treat another human being merely as
their body set of
systems that they're undergoing that
you're going to cure how does that come
across the other person do they feel
what's up you didn't say well I do care
I want you to get better
I you know I care about this this very
important thing that's what my skill
helps me with is your body and curing it
but then they could still say yeah but
you don't care in another important way
you're not showing me recognition as
another subject when you take away
somebody else's options in a certain way
you're depriving them of their
subjectivity you're treating them has
just enough and you don't like it when
people do that to you right so you
probably have a good sense that other
people do it it's good to that even if
you tell yourself you know now it could
get kind of complicated and what about
masochistic relationships we'll skip all
this that's that's like a whole
different discussion so that's that
first here's the second thing
Hegel is doing what I like to call the
the dialectical three step this is
pretty typical you have you know if you
ever come across Cagle on the net you'll
often see these turns your thesis
antithesis synthesis and the ideas that
you have with some sort of position and
that you have an opposite to that
position and then you bring those
together somehow and you achieve the
synthesis of a thesis of antithesis and
the thesis is always higher and better
and more comprehensive and now you've
completed a stage in the dialectic I
don't think that those terms are
particularly useful until you've been
studying Hangul for a while so I
wouldn't worry about them I'm certainly
not going to require you to no thesis
antithesis
for anything like that she is doing
something that fits that schema in this
session because he starts out talking
about consciousness in the abstract and
then he starts talking about life and
you notice he's got it divide it up into
sections right so that helps out he
starts talking about life you might say
well why is he going on about what well
you'll see why is below and then what's
bringing the both of these together is
this section called the ego and desire
and from there we're going to go to
talking about so business as another the
first we gotta get through this stuff so
I'm going to I'm going to lead you
through that very very very quickly he
talks about self consciousness as having
attained to this point I'm actually
going to skip over that we have this
beautiful phrase of these guises with
self-consciousness we've now casted the
native land of truth so when you're
actually conscious of yourself not just
as paying attention to all the things
out there but you're getting to know
about yourself - that's the native land
of truth you don't really know things
unless you also know yourself in
relation to those things into the
kingdom word is at home he says so
what's going on with us he brings up
this term that's particularly important
and talking about knowledge so far
another desire
and now thinking instead of focusing on
knowing the world
the ant acquiring knowledge of what's
out there pieces of chalk has gone up
spies classrooms universities you know
world history all that sort of stuff as
we go from the small to the to the great
think in terms of desire
why do you actually learn anything
because you want to know right sometimes
it's for you know what we would call
utilitarian purposes you need to get
through this class so you need to know
something about Hegel so you you know
you google him and Wikipedia comes up
right away and you you know click on the
entry and you learn a few things about
hangover right now imagine that you're
doing that you've clicked on it and
you've got yourself some basic
background knowledge because you wanted
to know not for its own sake but because
getting it through this class and you're
reading this those attacks feel like I
have no idea what this is talking about
bless you this doesn't make any sense
hopefully you know some article can help
me out with this how many of you start
out googling something and then you go
to Wikipedia and you start reading and
then you start clicking more links this
is by show of hands also a goodie after
the class why'd you click more links
very that's a very practical answer
there yeah
well that's interesting
because that you know I mean Hegel's not
talking about Wikipedia or anything like
that alright cuz it didn't exist in his
time but that trying to assure that's
that's what he calls certainty there's
truth and then there's certainty
something impossible positive Sophos
being true but you don't know that
that's actually the case that's why you
got to watch out with Wikipedia alright
you get more something that interests
you yeah and this can happen this is
very unpredictable isn't it you never
know what's actually gonna interest you
because you're motivated by desire we
learn because we want to learn because
we're attracted to things because we
want to consume them Hegel would say we
want to make them part of our own
consciousness sometimes we actually do
want to consume things the word he asked
for desired Goethe and German can mean
hunger too you think about eating when
you're Eve you want to get to know
something you want to get to know the
thing that you're putting into your and
hear your mouth and chewing up and
tasting and once you're done it's all
gone right nobody else can taste that
particular thing unless you're doing
something really strange you know like
pretending to be a mama bird or
something but even though it's not
really the same thing there's somebody
who's into it probably has a Wikipedia
entry right the quoted some of you
looking up after class not because you
really want to do that but because you
have morbid curiosity about it there's
other things that when we when we take
them in when we make them our own we
don't we leave them behind for other
people knowledge just like that right so
if I've learned Hegel I'm not taking
Cagle away from you it's not like
there's a limit
a lot of hagel that my mind can chew up
and your mind can't really mind us
matter of fact we can do it together but
we are motivated by by desire we want to
like it says consciousness this is
something essential to it desire in
general consciousness he has as self
consciousness a two-fold object the one
immediate the object of sense certainty
and perception which is marked by the
character of negation things never turn
out to be exactly the way that we think
of them the second which is the truth
essence and it's found in the first
instance only in the opposition first
object to it so you try to learn things
in the world they resist don't they
this is the world just like a we got to
help remember that scene in the matrix
where Keanu Reeves has his epiphany at
the very end and everything rings into
code and he can see everything you guys
remember that scene then he can like it
he'll start killing about the agents and
doing all sorts of damage is life like
that do you have do you have moments
where like the entirety of your
experience suddenly turns into a massive
code and everything makes perfect sense
to you when you're reading listen on
even pick Hegel cuz handle stuff when
you were reading Hume did everything
just immediately make sense to you as
you were reading it or did you have to
struggle yeah I have to struggle to
still sometimes I still strongly desire
and struggle go together what's going on
there
and as you are trying to make that
object part of your consciousness we
were trying to assimilate it to yourself
you're trying to bring it into your own
sphere and make it your own because we
are motivated by this desire to do so in
doing so you have to do
when Eagle is calling annulling the
object or negating the object you have
to treat it as if it's information to
you and not just some independent thing
outside of you because if you treat it
is just something purely extrinsic
external to you you'll never get to know
it you'll never experience once you
bring it into your field of
consciousness you can't experience you
can come to know it but it does still
exist as something independent doesn't
it that does still continue to exist you
that offers you new appearances now this
piece of Sherlock is not going to offer
you an awful lot right but imagine a
landscape something still that's not
really super living you know we're not
focusing on life as such you know you're
focusing on saying let's say we pick a
desert landscape right do you take in
the entirety of that landscape and some
of you might like thunder glance capes
do you take it in and in one moment you
come back the next day that looks
different doesn't it and you see that a
different life it looks different you
are getting to learn more and more about
it and you can do that because it exists
on its own independence of view you can
bring it into your field of
consciousness but you can't make it into
something that's totally your own that
you completely dominate there's nothing
to learn from but you can learn it
essential features now when we get the
living things like it says life is a bit
different think about how much
complexity life introduces two things
piece of charm is not going to defend
itself
matter of fact that's why I can scribble
it all over the board right poor thing
gets used up should we even feel pity
for it though I mean you could feel
sorry for the people
look something more worn away we're
actually answered from horrifies all
right this chalk doesn't feel anything
it doesn't care it's not the sort of
thing that does what some animals do
they resist their own destruction try to
you know try to kill a cockroach right
that's that's a great example some of
you may have had cockroaches or her
dance particularly bad this time of year
as soon as it tells it that you have
some sort of hostile attention towards
you what happens
that's campers away as soon as you start
moving actually or a fly you're not
buzzing around here room you want to
kill it as soon as it's like as soon as
it starts to become aware that you're
gonna try to destroy it it resists
that's because life actually wants to
continue on life is a new level of
complexity it's not yet so consciousness
fly is not thinking about what is the
meaning of fly life should I should I
actually dodge the flyswatter or is it
all pointless is it just reproduction
and and rotting meat and then laying
eggs and stuff like that or is there a
greater purpose it says it's not doing
self-consciousness like that but it is
alive and it is trying to continue in
its life and the fly is interested in
certain things gets motivated by desire
right even the plants that we are
motivated by desire for something what
do they want growth eating certain
things air water sunlight suppose we
have focuses that
not like so much similar not quite but
other things and like he says life
itself we can understand and I'm
skipping through this fairly quickly
life we can understand in two different
ways you can think of life with a
capital L like every living thing we've
these days called biosphere the totality
of the existing things but you can also
think of life as splitting itself into
all these little hearts all these
organisms each of which is its own kind
of center of existence it may not
necessarily have consciousness like we
do but each of them strives to do
certain things each of them is motivated
by certain desires not necessarily
desires like we feel I don't know that
we can analogize to a plant you know say
wanting to reproduce and compare that to
our instinct to reproduce but you know
you can tell plant wants something
because it does something does it fairly
naturally and as we go up and up the
scale these things get more and more
complex don't they like what are some
things that for example mammals want the
reptiles don't seem to care much about
yeah no they all do they have a lead
oxygen animal life right
well something more in terms of like how
how mammals were mammals how how we're
different than reptiles were fish or
other quite advanced beings yeah
reptiles have desires to do I mean you
know a snake wants to eat the rat that
falls into its cage
and if you poke that snake a couple
times it's going to want to bite you you
know they don't even tell you it's got a
wrap hey bite you in poison you if you
don't knock it off you know so they have
you know some sort of structure we have
a part of our brain it's called the
reptilian brain the real inner part part
that handles the fight-or-flight
response the part that handles certain
emotions like fear forgiving that that
part is confidence it's deep inside our
brain yes Samantha yeah mammals
sometimes seek companionship whatever
snakes nicely yeah I mean snakes kind of
like to hang out with other snakes at
certain times things get those big balls
of rioting snakes but it's usually about
mating mammals like to hang out with
other mammals and sometimes many of
their own species and then even see
these birds due to monthly you ever seen
his video this was linked to the animals
playing together they somehow grew up
together it's a weird way like a hippo
and an elephants you know they're not
even the same species but they're able
to play with each other they do have a
desire they desire that the reptile
doesn't have to play if we go even
further down insects don't play we do
other other animals do as well there's
this great one with camp and an owl
hello there's a hawk it flies down and
the cat tries to jump up and get it and
you're like wow that's a that's pretty
amazing cat right there and then the the
owl swings around and it comes back and
it keeps coming back over and over again
and you realize these two are playing
with each other they actually enjoy this
this is part of their interaction they
don't know any better that's not
they can you know play tag or something
else all they know is I'm gonna fly and
you're going to try to catch me it's not
advanced but it shows some sort of
advance in life and what happens is you
know Hegel's talking about if we look at
life itself and we look at
self-consciousness we become aware of
ourselves
there's no longer to being this abstract
knowledge based thing but as living
beings each one of you has a life your
life is something continuous it places
you in continuity with all the other
things that are out there but it is it a
harmonious and let's all get along and a
Disney kind of continuity no because
what kind of creature argue about it how
do you get by you consume other life
right even if you're a vegetarian you're
consuming of life you're just consuming
vegetable life animal life and that's
part of this you know we have this big
the cycle of life or the circle of life
it's not really a circle it's more like
a hold it's more like a free-for-all
like Hunger Games you know there are
copia thing where they open it up and
they're all like you know some of them
are killing each other and some of them
are taking off that's a pretty good a
blow
you know there's this circle of life
business that people are talking about
it's very messy it's always changing the
one thing that you can count on though
is that it's always going to be until
you have it like some sort of nucular
everybody lost you know some other
catastrophic event it's always going to
be adapting individual beings may not
exist they may not preserve but there
will always be something living
there'll always be something adapting
there'll always be something making the
world its own at least the part of the
world that it understands were unique in
that potentially the entire world is
ours
cockroach only sees this this amount of
things you know that's really good at
what it does
giraffe sees another
you know the spider sees another part
that has to do sometimes eating
cockroaches we can take in the hole
that's we're different let's move past
life now and get to the ego and desire
so this is the section where solid ate
everything starting to bring everything
together
he says self-consciousness is assured of
itself through overcoming through what
he calls sub lading the souther which is
presented to self-consciousness as an
independent life self-consciousness is
desired and you're doing this all the
time you're doing this with your own
life through doing this with the lives
of other things you're doing this with
the objects you encounter and he says
when self-consciousness actually negates
the the other thing you know then it
becomes currently become certain of its
own self part of the way in which we we
adapt to our environment is like I said
making it our own
and when we do that we elevate ourselves
above it that's why when you get thrown
into an unfamiliar environment you feel
that loss and then you feel kind of
uneasy you don't quite know how to get
around whereas in a familiar environment
everything exists for you I would say it
is your own and that's how you deep down
the side that's how you continually keep
yourself sort of elevated you know in
your own purview you you feel good when
that's the case when everything is
familiar to you you feel that all right
you're able to get by think about you
know what when it texts make sense to
you when a text doesn't make sense to
you you feel kind of at a loss you feel
uncertainty you may actually feel like
that I hate this this stupid thing get
it okay for me right but when you
actually understand something a text a
movie a song pick whatever you like a
procedure you've made it your own and
you
you are on the top of your game you feel
like you are in charge of everything
that feeling that he's talking about is
what he means by certainty of your own
self a true certainty so he says in this
state of satisfaction there's a
back-and-forth going on here we have
experience of the independence of the
object desire and the certainty of its
self obtained and the gratification of
desire are conditioned by the object so
in your life you have this continual
back-and-forth process that has to go on
that he has been awakened and it's going
to continue to occur but at higher
levels you set for yourself things that
you are interested in for example all of
you right now are engaged in the project
of being a college student right this is
important to you I think otherwise you
wouldn't be here
this is Community College we paid you
know 4000 bucks a year for tuition maybe
that wouldn't be the case maybe you know
that's better than you know staying in
the basement and watching TV you know
this is this is an actual project here
you try to make everything your own
because you have desire to do so you
figure out who you are and what your
value is by bringing everything into
consciousness for yourself by mastering
it at the same time when you do that you
feel strong satisfaction in doing that
it really only retains value for you if
this thing over here remains to some
degree independent you know how many of
you play playing video games of one form
or another at any sort of video games
thanks for the challenge gamers when you
get to the point where it becomes too
easy doesn't it become boring
yeah yeah depends on what you're doing I
mean you look you like having imagine
you've got cheat codes right you can
always think you can all relate to this
you can type in cheat codes for certain
games and get like unlimited everything
the game at that point it can be fun for
a little while but then it can become
extremely boring we like to have
challenges yeah already heard he just
like mowing things down or solving
whatever puzzles and just when things
come easy to people what happens to them
they start to get bored and then they
what's up well they don't learn anything
for one thing this is a big problem in
schools too by the way if you're not in
the students are challenged they get
bored and then they start engaging and
all sorts of bad activities because they
want to do something that actually has
some challenge to like you know you see
my can sneak out of class we're gonna do
this thing over here like we used to do
in high school that's the object
non-existing as independent free
becoming totally girl when it does
become totally your own it's less
satisfying then when it still has some
challenges for you when there's still a
back-and-forth so he says the object
desired in fact is something other than
self-consciousness it's the essence of
desire and it's talking about desire in
terms of our individual desires is also
talking about desire in general and what
is we talked about this was a little bit
earlier what is it gonna be most
designer quit life be satisfying for you
if all the other people were gone
there's a Twilight Zone episode like
that that you may have run across it's
kind of funny there's a lot of pop
cultural references to it
this guy he's I think a bank clerk and
there's a nuclear holocaust or something
but it's
a kind of bomb that just kills people
disappears people and leaves all the
buildings and stuff like that intact
this guy's never had enough time to read
he really likes reading but he's a bank
clerk and he's got a lot of worries and
people are always bugging him when he's
trying to read so everybody's gone now
and now he actually has enough time to
read now you know you might say well
that's not really all people being gone
right because what is reading it's been
gauging with another mind isn't it so
it's just a select group of people he
wants to hang out with people who don't
talk unless we open up the pages which
is pretty you know together you know he
wants to have objects he can master and
then what happens to the poor guy isn't
anybody seen that episode for this glass
while he's using nearsighted you can't
read her those glasses they fall right
he's like all by himself totally all by
himself now you might say late get a pet
cat you know the cats didn't all die so
he fights floppy and expensive you know
petting fluffy that can be challenging
or maybe he learns to play a musical
instrument all the instrument stores are
still open
well whatever you like with that life
still be satisfied now no matter how
much stuff you pee again
would it really be satisfying without
the look of other people without
interaction with other people if you
said yes there's the you're probably
like Aristotle says a beast or a god
those who can live you know totally on
their own us human beings we need other
human beings
that's because consciousness like he
says self consciousness attains its
satisfaction only in another self
consciousness so he says it's in these
three moments the notion of self
consciousness
it's completed first undifferentiated
ego is the first immediate object the
immediacy is mediation it becomes desire
becomes life the satisfaction of desire
is the reflection of self-consciousness
into itself and the truth of this
certainty is reduplicating of
self-consciousness this entire process
that we have right here gets mirrored
and every other person that we come
across and here you might say well that
sounds great you know in the individual
people exist for each other we can all
be one big happy harmonious radiations
now I look at you you look at me for all
them big happy family we don't like each
other I get my validation from you knew
your validation from me we have this
thing that we follow recognition passing
between us does that the way human
relations actually work oh yeah we have
what we call personality conflicts no
matter what you know sooner or later you
find somebody you don't know it doesn't
you what do we go a little bit deeper
what else keeps us from all being one
baby happy family yeah something we'll
just lately there's there's a proper to
some people
[Music]
yeah we look at each other
instrumentally everybody's yeah now
we're really getting to what Hagel is
talking about this is gonna leave by the
way to what he calls the struggle very
dramatic you know all of their lives to
make sure it stress how dramatic this is
part of what Hagel thinks that
self-consciousness is want is this
recognition from other
self-consciousness yeah it seems like
there's never enough of this to go
around we want to be recognized by other
people we want to be treated as if we
matter as if we have dependent existence
but often times we can only do that by
using other people and if you have to
sub consciousnesses both of whom like
encounter each other in the wild and
they say hello that's another one of me
right over there and then the other one
says I know you've got it wrong you're
another one of me you've already got a
conflict don't you and Hagel says they
have to struggle to the death and what's
going to happen if there's going to be
dialectical advancement is that one of
them killed the other one in which case
the whole thing is repeats itself right
because if one of the existence is one
where they both kill each other
they got no no progress what else can
happen well once the consciousness is
can't become the dominant one as one of
them can become the inferior one what
happens on playgrounds throw kids
together they don't struggle with the
death
thank God right because otherwise we'd
be real trouble but not like that
species of sharks where you know like
some of them inside the womb eat each
other you know the ones that I survived
but the toughest you guys know about
this kind of gruesome tiger sharks tiger
sharks to them because they were there
we go kids some kids on top that's you
know usually pretty rational somebody's
the biggest kid tip it's the kill you
it's like willing to go to the extreme
and say I'm gonna face you down then
some of the kid like actually buckles
under and says oh okay okay you know you
have to be willing to put something up
to that stake Hegel things in order to
to have this kind of encounter yeah you
know we do this to each other in in
small trivial ways guys are bad for this
for like you know handshakes you know
how many of you guys experienced this
somebody who like wants to crush your
hand and show you what a tough guy they
are no yeah maybe that's more of a you
know my generation kind of thing there's
still some guys who want to do that some
women to now really squeeze your hand
really hard I'm sure you know that's a
dominance thing too or just reaction
against it you know because you don't
want to be like a week fishy Kenney
handshake either all right that's that
sudden you up for people saying from a
fishy handshake yeah we have a kind of
sense that well that's kind of weak we
we have a lot of the superior that
appeals to things that are going on
within us and it's sort of unconscious
now what's going on here is this
self-consciousness is able to use this
other self-consciousness to get the
recognition that it wants the other you
know the other self consciousness exists
or the other this self-consciousness
this or it's so yeah the world ends up
getting split into different kinds of
self-consciousness those who are for
themselves and we get to call the shots
and get them to run the show and tell
other people what to do and those who
are stuck sucking it up and you know
either obeying or you know running into
some sort of problem and they end up
giving the other the recognition that
they want now here's where we get to the
master-slave dialectic and here's where
it gets really really interesting and we
only have a few minutes so I'm going to
run through this fairly quickly this is
the master this is the sweater so let's
let's do a little bit of a shake let's
put it over here and we'll put the
master I love this sound good they make
sense slave gives recognition to the
master was the master give in return not
recognition jobs you know this is what
you need to do and a few other things to
Hegel will actually I'm going to skip a
little a little bit of half table I'll
say that the master gives recognition to
the master and the master gets enjoyment
because of that the slave is three
things from the master one is fear the
slave is made to fear for their very
being for their identity for their
existence in some cases and it doesn't
have to be you know slavery in a sense
that were necessarily thinking about you
know or
Antebellum slavery or you know even like
sex slavery that goes on today still
with the sex trade think about when
somebody threatens to fire you from the
job that you've got that you've held for
five years you're paying off your
student loans you could take it out a
number of other student loans you've got
a mortgage you've got you've got a
spouse who still hasn't found a job yet
and kids and think about how invested
Americans get in our jobs and we make
that into our very identity somebody
bless you somebody who's your boss says
if you don't do what I say you're out of
here we'll find somebody else to fill
your spots that I think could cause that
kind of fear that Hagel is talking about
that shapes one's very being Hinkle
talks about in terms of lash does he's
thinking about in traditional slavery
the master also gives work why because
the master wants to enjoy him or herself
and the best way to do that is by making
the the slave work on objects if the
master doesn't want to do you know it
could be as silly as like you know peel
the grapes for me like we see these old
you know Roman movies or things like
that or it could be like you're going to
the salt mines you're gonna you're gonna
mind my salt or you're gonna work on the
assembly line or you you know you're
gonna watch the tutor the children or
any of these these sorts of things the
slave is made to engage with work that
the master doesn't want to do those are
those who are both important then there
is what we call let's call it obedience
anal talks about the interpolation of
the lash if you want to get somebody to
be productive and you're not going to be
able to write you know love or soft
respect or something like that what do
you have to do is it enough to scare the
hell out of them once what do you think
No is that enough to like scare them on
every occasion that you want to work out
of them that's a lot of work for you if
you're the master right what you want is
somebody who's got a little image of the
master inside their their mind you know
saying I'm watching you you better stay
in line
better get your work done better get get
on that quota cuz otherwise I'm going to
come down on to you
you want them to internalize as Hegel
says the lash you want them to make the
Masters consciousness for the growth you
want them to define themselves in terms
of their activities now here's where the
story gets particularly interesting
where there's a twist
who's going to develop I mean the master
seems like they have all the advantages
don't then they get to enjoy everything
they get to tell the slave what to do
they get to make them into what they
want
well we want a bunch of workers you're
all going to have to take on that
mentality in order to do that or even oh
we change our production schedules now
we want you all to be teachers you're
all going to study educational now we
want musicians everybody find an
instrument they log and learn it really
well because if you don't you're in
trouble you know it's like every asset
similar we collect very clever honest
it's an old movie it's got a really
funny lineup they're talking about first
place is you get this great vacation
it's a selling contest sales contest
second place is you get this this nice
that third place is your fight
you're gonna have a bad so this sounds
like the master gets to run the show
right pretty good for them are they
developing
yeah that turns out to be really work is
on objects the world reality when you
work it that you don't like and you're
actually paying attention to things
because you don't like the job and you
want to get through it as as quickly as
possible you're something to these other
things like you know you know your
velocity is gonna fire you if you don't
do it and you're worried about you know
who you're gonna be if you get fired you
get to know your subject really well you
actually learn things about the world
and about yourself in the process the
slave develops remember this is
reflective thing with consciousness we
develop through engaging our environment
the slave but let's let's think about
cooking for example if you work in a
kitchen do you go up to the culinary
they still have the brigade system which
means that in the old-school way of
doing things you learn to say yes chef
to everything and you do really tough
stuff that's changing the environment is
changing out it's becoming much more
like like regular education but there's
still in some respect this mentality if
the chef tells you to jump through fire
to jump through fire why because you're
more afraid of the chef than the fire
and you have to learn to internalize the
show to become obedient and you have to
cut you know if you want to clear knife
skills you have to cook thing after
thing after thing after thing food and
probably sometimes your own fingers in
the process until your hands are sore
and then you will acquire them if you
want to learn an instrument you really
want to learn it well if it hurts you
know if you play guitar you know you get
those calluses on your fingertips all
right if you're gonna be a dancer have
you ever seen Black Swan those little
scenes where she's like you know nursing
her feet that's what he happens if
you're gonna dance competitive
you've gotta really work hard now in
doing that you develop you actually
through work you become something
greater than you were so where is the
movement through history is it a part of
the masters or is it on the part of the
the slaves it's actually on the part of
the slaves
this is cables little you know surprise
twist thing same thing if you think
about education we make you do all sorts
of things that perhaps you don't like to
do if this is a model for education then
you know you you actually work on things
you acquire something that perhaps the
jerk professor who you know assigned you
all this work and told you that well
this is just what's expected of you if
you don't do it you're giving it up you
know they made you develop and perhaps
surpassed them in the process so that's
the self-consciousness all the way up to
the master-slave dialectic
[Music]